hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor i've got quite a
big property portfolio now i've been
investing in property for over 10 years
can you believe it and i've also trained
tens of thousands of people also to
invest successfully in property so in
this video i wanted to talk about buy
refurbish refinance rent this is a
strategy that we call
or brr i don't want to call it and
effectively it's when you buy a house
and rather than leaving your money in
probably just buying a house putting 25
deposit in and then leaving your money
in and getting a return on investment
with the burst strategy by refurbishing
finance rent you want to buy the house
but you buy it cheap and then you
refurbish it so when you bought this
then how much work needed to be done and
now it's fully refurbished what was it
like when you got it and how much work
have you done uh so it was slightly run
down it was like an only couple that
owned it for many years
yeah yeah we stripped pretty much
everything out and you push the value up
and then you
refinance it so they bought it for 24
and a half
a few months ago november
2020
and then
just got a loan
from t-side money
for 37 and a half
which means you pulled out
all of your money yeah
plus
12 and a half minus your refurb say 10
grand yeah
that's ridiculous
so basically they got paid 10 000 pounds
to have the house
pull your money back out and then rent
it out andrew you're happy here
are you happy here yes it's a nice house
i like it yeah good so you're paying
three seven five yeah
and how long have you been here three
months and how long do you plan to stay
a couple years at least yeah good good
well they talk only good things about
you and the idea of it is is that you
take a small pot of money and instead of
leaving it into a house you put it in
take it out put it in take it out put it
in take it out i've been doing this for
10 years and this is how you can take a
small little pot of money and you can
continue to recycle it recycle it buying
more and more houses over and over again
for free rather than working really hard
saving up a deposit and buying a house
saving up a deposit buying a house they
don't work hard and save up money what
they do is they creatively finance their
deals doing things like buy refurbished
refinance rent so i actually found this
property on rightmove and it was on the
market for 70 000 pounds now because it
needs a lot of work chances are i'll be
able to put in a very cheeky offer and
it may just well be accepted so i
offered to buy the property for 64 000
pounds and they said yes which was a
little bit of a bargain considering that
there's others selling in the street
that are exactly the same but in good
condition for anywhere from 85 right up
to past 90 000 pounds i know the
darlington is a very cheap area but the
ha the rents are reasonably high so it
fits in with my buy low rent high
formula to firstly find the type of deal
that's going to be able to
work as a brr deal and secondly you have
to rely on builders you have to make
sure that you know what the end value is
going to be
so far first impressions is a really
important thing because the valuer
before he even walks into the house is
gonna have a figure in his mind
i like what they've done on the outside
they've painted it clearly before it was
like horrible
dirty stone so that's good but i'm not
particularly impressed with all the mess
that's left outside all these paint
brushes and fanta cans i mean come on
when you're paying builders to do the
work on your property you don't expect
them to leave a mess like this but
anyway let's hope that inside is a bit
better and i'm feeling impressed on the
inside have a look
[Music]
okay
pretty pretty tightly really i've put a
new
new fire which is a lot better
wouldn't be my choice of carpet but
it looks nice this is fine
also i wouldn't have put blinds i would
have put curtains but again
kind of preference
yeah like it
oh this is nice
i'm really pleased with this
i'm so glad
that we went with a whole new kitchen
[Music]
what can i say i'd live here myself
buy them really cheap then get a nice
kitchen get a nice bathroom push the
value up refinance afterwards it's a
much smarter way to buy a property if
you're doing a buy refurbished refinance
deal it does work in london or the
outskirts of london very well it also
works in cheaper areas some pros and
cons i'll say is the pros of doing it
near london is number one you live there
so you're gonna be able to manage the
property easier and also you know the
area well and you need to know the area
well
the cons of doing it in or around london
is houses are really expensive so you're
going to probably need more money
initially to put down up front even
though you'll hopefully get it back up
on the refinance but also when you do
refinance it might be that the rent
doesn't really cover the mortgage
because houses are so expensive around
london so it might be better starting
off further up north you get the
experience up north you'll be able to
get more cash flow and then once you've
understand the strategy and you've done
it potentially consider moving uh closer
to home but there really are pros and
cons to each so i would just say make
sure you're comfortable you know the
area well and ultimately the numbers
stack up